militante du parti socialiste depuis
claude darciaux a toujours mené de front
sa carrière de professeur de
mathématiques
son engagement politique et sa vie de
famille conseiller municipal depuis 1983
puis première adjointe
elle est finalement élu maire de longvic
en 2005 en 2002 elle devient surtout la
première femme parlementaire de
côte-d'or ça me semble important
aujourd'hui une femme soit reconnue
député de la côte d'or et la première
donc j'en suis fier de porter cette
responsabilité en 2012 et après deux
mandats au palais bourbon
claude darciaux décide de se consacrer
exclusivement à sa commune ça a été pour
moi disant ma vie quelque chose
d'inoubliable quelque chose
d'extraordinaire j'ai beaucoup travaillé
c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit que nous le
des mandats c'est pas quelque chose de
facile à vivre je suis alors là vraiment
totalement contre le cumul des mandats
loi sur le non cumul des mandats ou sur
la parité
ces dernières années le monde de la
politique c'est un peu transformé les
choses évoluent mais doucement parce que
vous savez les hommes y sont pour la
parité
ils sont pour que les femmes fassent de
la politique à condition qu'on ne prenne
pas leur place
fidèle à ses valeurs cette femme
politique souhaite aujourd'hui laissé la
place à une nouvelle génération dans un
mois elle ne brillera pas de troisième
mandat de maire parce que le temps du
renouveau de redynamiser un moment donné
il faut savoir s'arrêter je crois que
c'est la sagesse et peut-être que les
femmes non plus que les hommes pour sa
retraite politique claude darciaux déjà
un programme
il est simple profiter de ses proches et
de tout ce temps libre qui s'offrent
maintenant elle